yes
I think our sponsor bird dog you bet we
do bird dogs are the only shorts that
actually fit because the material
stretches around you they look nice you
got khaki shorts but they function like
your best pair of gym shorts so go to
birddogs.com DPT and enter the promo
code DPT for a free Yeti style tumbler
which I have and is amazing with your
order that's birddogs.com DPT enter
promo code DPT for a free Yeti style
tumbler hey townies welcome to another
episode of dumb people Town population
mints
welcome to the show one of our favorite
colors how are you sir so kind thank you
beautiful voice on one of our favorite
shows you would it's a Bob's Burgers
Reunion yeah I think because this last
time there was I wasn't at a table read
I don't think but when I first did flip
swipe fudge we were all in this huge
room this guy asked me if I could scoot
over and I was like yeah sure I was in
Trader Joe's when they were like do you
want to do an episode oh wow and I said
I said I go that's rhetorical like does
anyone say no do I want to be a part of
my favorite it would be like absolutely
not can you imagine that also if it's
like the worst show ever it's so easy
it's only like for yeah yeah like I
don't want to screw this up and then
yeah right for sag minimum right so I
didn't know anybody but I was at the
table read and I think you might have
been everywhere it was like brand new
offices you guys got not the ones that
they have now the ones before and uh
somebody was like you might scooting
like oh no not at all and then I'm like
shooting the [__] with this guy and I
hadn't met anybody I told John's the
only person I really knew uh Chris
Christian a little bit and um
I found out like once we started the
read after 20 minutes of like Hobb now
I'm shooting the [__] that Lauren was
the one next to me and I was like oh by
the way you should
be nervous yeah yeah yeah yeah so great
to be reunited our voices at least yeah
I love it so Dan you know in this uh I
say Dan Dan Mintz Daniel Dan so Dan uh
the world is just a dumb place and it
continues to get dumber and the only way
we fight back right is through comedy
sure so sometimes I feel like we're the
people who like made a picnic and
watched the Civil War
we're just like did you bring the
potatoes it but we will look at it and
talk about what the boat that like drove
by the Titanic and they're like wait did
that really happen no
you guys good
crazy thing happening like 100 miles
that way let's see right let's go check
that out you guys have a hole in your
boat you know I think that's a flare I
think that's a firework they party on
that boat you know there's like people
like in bikinis going by the Titanic
[Applause]
all right so
the Titanic
did you this is horrible but did you
guys see the meme where they were like
they were like the new ghosts showing up
to the Titanic because because of the
sub and they were like hey uh
how did you guys get it took you a long
time to get here we actually we we we
came here we came down here to see you
guys
so terrible it's terrible we can laugh
at it terrible Dan we could laugh at it
cause they're billionaires
right like no one has any sympathy
you got the first yeah you want to do it
okay here we go this was sent in by Brew
pounder at brewpounder Thank you new uh
my guess is from Milwaukee they said
this on August 5th which of last year
which is my birthday
all right here we go open fridge eaten
yogurt sounds like I'm doing uh yeah I
mean I'm prompting you so this doesn't
count that is yes
leads to arrest in Austintown
oh my God not Austin Texas you think
they're trying to keep Austintown normal
we're not are we talking about a town in
Austin or Austin Texas
oh that's a great yeah where is Austin
Ohio so they are trying to keep it
normal hey man keep Austin down to
normal if they don't sell that merch
they dies get on it okay yes I mean they
are definitely trying to be more normal
than Portland Town
Northern Town's going the other way wait
didn't wasn't there a period where
Portland had key Portland Weird weirder
then and then Austin had Keep Austin
Weird right they were both like Keep
Portland Weird in Austin yeah back and
forth because the other Portland doesn't
even bother with the town Portland Maine
yeah yeah at least Austintown at least
tries to make be clear
yeah these two one in Maine the one in
Maine has shirts that says we're the
town Stephen King meant right
do you know that story Rob Reiner didn't
find out to like into production do you
understand that Rob Reiner thought he
meant Portland Oregon and in the novella
the body first stand by me and it was
until they were in the production that
he found out it was Maine and he was
like well it's too late too late I don't
care this is what we're doing we're
gonna be in Oregon okay uh Austintown
Ohio
WKBN thank you a Youngstown man so he
traveled yeah was booked into the
Mahoning County jail after police say he
went inside a stranger's home and
appeared to have helped himself to food
and clothes that it could be confusion
wait have you ever had a break-in or a
burglarization of your car I have not
knock knock
we have of our car of our car when we
were in college we shared a car
let's change the presets and all NPR
which was so weird like why are we doing
everything are you uh no but then but it
felt they didn't take anything sure [__]
was like rustled around and I felt super
violated so I have not had a break in
but just in case I always write my name
on my yogurt
yeah or like Camp Laura said like a
thief comes in and opens up Dan's thing
and it's like I'm just gonna take oh
sorry
yeah clearly labeled and that's my wife
it might be great if not if somebody
broke in but if they opened your fridge
and we're like [__] with their names on
it Dan's like well I told my wife you
get a Better Label
it uh oh on Sunday Austintown police
officers responded to a call from a home
owner I don't know why I keep doing that
stating that an unknown man was inside
his house according to the police report
wait he's in the house when they called
yes oh my God that's terrible well I
hope for some reason I hope it's
non-threatening like there's a tick tock
that just went viral where this guy
stormed into a nail salon
tried to Rob them and they could and no
one no one reacted they all just were
like
and he kept going give me all the money
and no one responded and he you could
see him lose his steam right very
quickly like well I'm leaving then and
he leaves guys last chance
look if you want to get robbed today I'm
not giving you another chance he walks
out and comes second is like I just need
a pedicure
I feel like we got off of the wrong side
yeah literally maybe I'm not good at
entrances and they treat it like an
audition why don't you go out go outside
do it for you I have the 11 15. I
thought you were trying to do that for
us do it for you yeah just let them do a
hey you know what throw some of that
away yeah
um but I'm hoping it was that
non-threatening that the guy was like
I'm looking at him stop put that down
no you use the small spoon that's not
gonna fit right
um okay where was I so he was inside his
house according to the police report the
homeowner left his home shortly before 5
PM to go out and eat when he returned
home around 7 30 kind of a long dinner
he noticed that his refrigerator and
cupboard doors were open after he closed
the doors he noticed an unknown man
standing in the back bedroom okay
now to me the clothes this is like
classic horror movie you'd close success
remember the scene in The Sixth Sense
when she walks out of the kitchen it's
great
[Laughter]
yes don't overthink it yeah my Dinner
with Andre with Bruce Willis yes I just
watched that movie How High were you
Amy's in my wife's in the other room
she's like doing something I'm like I'm
gonna watch My Dinner with Andre and I
sat and watched the entire thing really
yes and I'm like this is Phenom like
he's gonna keep talking and the more
that the guy Andre is talking the more
I'm like what he's talking about sounds
like he went to burning man I'm like I
know Burning Man didn't exist in 1980
but I'm like oh I'm sure Dad I'm sure
there's four people that still talk yeah
we were in that desert in 81 before but
he's like we were dancing and then we
were doing all these hand movements and
then we started crying and then she held
me I'm like that's [__] Burning Man
have you guys have you seen my Dinner
with Andre no I have not does it hold up
yeah right it kind of does is it good
like should I watch I don't even think
yeah I'd rather go to dinner so but you
have to be in the mode it's brilliant
you have to be in the mindset of like
I'm gonna sit and walk it's definitely
not like an episode of the bear so I
would I would recommend watching
Mike blyden's Bob Odenkirk directed
Melvin goes to dinner yeah which is
that's maybe you're being serious I am
have you seen that I've never been so
blind so Matt price our buddy Matt price
Stephanie Courtney Stephanie Courtney
and Annabelle gurwich those four people
are kind of for stranger or friends like
acquaintances who meet at like a dinner
kind of at this restaurant and they shot
it was a play first called fire Giants
and then they shot 69 pages in one night
five cameras they ran through it twice
wow and then they shot a bunch of like
offshoots flashbacks and Flash arounds
and that's what this is just their
dinner
when he returned home around 7 30 long
dinner he noticed that his refrigerator
cover doors are open six cents according
to the police report Alexander Solomon
his name was Alexander Solomon
and there's a lot of things he has done
most of them illegal this is the guy who
broke in is Alexander Solomon is that
his name his name is Alexander and
there's a lot of yogurt he hasn't tried
just you win just you with God damn but
his dad went to get cigarettes quick
okay
I never understood that Dan we we talk
about this in the show in this upcoming
show we wrote the the guy who goes out
to get cigarettes and doesn't come back
what are you gonna you got one pair of
underwear one she's gonna leave all your
clothes or they're leaving out the part
we're like so my dad's like carrying all
this luggage off to the car it's weird
he's got two duffel bags he's just going
for a cigarettes back in the car we're
not going on vacation
uh okay when you return on 7 30. the
homeowner uh Alexander Solomon was
standing in the room wearing a Cleveland
Cavaliers jersey and underwear I mean
are we sure it wasn't Delonte West yeah
he stated that to the homeowner that he
was there with the cleaning service
that's a great okay come up with that on
the spot or was he I think it's a pretty
good on the spot it's not a good like in
advance thinking of advancing no but for
improv great as an improv that's amazing
so can I just say this because I'm gonna
link these two things
this is one of my most my pet peeves
with my wife is when I'm doing the
dishes because she cooks she's amazing
cook it's much better that she's cooking
and I'm not cooking okay and I'm like
I'll clean it up I don't want you to
touch the thing I'll clean it up but as
I'm doing like dishes and pots and pans
there's always like a lot of stuff
there's always like six more pots than
we really need and I'm doing it I'm
scrubbing and everything and then like
as I'm doing it she'll bring out stuff
from the fridge that needs to be thrown
away or be cleaned out and I'm like oh
we're doing this now I didn't realize in
the middle of me doing it we're doing
this now it was it's like terrible like
I hate cleaning out the fridge because
number one I always like to eat the food
we buy I never like to throw anythings
away and number two just more work on
top of the world like as long as you're
working here let's make the rest let's
make it so you can't watch it you can't
watch My Dinner with Andre tonight let's
just add all this dishes if this guy
came into my house and said I was just
cleaning out your fridge for you I'd be
like thanks yeah
also he's like I don't have a clean
service the guy and then the guy he just
keeps with the Improv well you need one
yes this is
there with a cleaning service uh that's
what he told him the homeowner stated
that he has lived at that location alone
for two years you know it's okay buddy
[Laughter]
there's two endings of that sentence Dan
one ending is I've been living here for
two years so if you know anybody right
or I've been living here alone for two
years because I'm a big boy bye bye one
elf one is pride and the other is like I
do everything by myself
or it's like he swallows it a little bit
it's like and I've um I live alone right
so if you know her
the door's unlocked
tell me have you seen it you just
started singing If you see her tell her
I'm sorry and I guess I got a cleaning
service so that takes care of some of
the issues she had she's too while I was
doing the dishes help me clean tell her
I'm fine he's lifted the location alone
for two years and does not know Solomon
guys the sentence itself is crazy he
felt like he needed to to tell the
reporter I've lived here and he doesn't
live here no I don't know him I've been
here two years that guy's never lived
here before today like Dan said is he's
like now involved in an improv he didn't
want to be in yeah right at some point
he's like how long are we gonna do this
when officers arrived the owner said
that Solomon was still in the bedroom
it's messy yes he was giving commands by
police to come outside which he did
still cleaning still cleaning yeah but I
also assumed what he comes out yeah I'm
in the middle of it officers walked
through the house and reported finding a
pair of shoes by the bedroom that the
homeowner said were not his so he took
his shoes off a TV and dresser were
moved and an empty container of yogurt
on top of the dresser that the homeowner
said had been in the refrigerator before
he left the house so this is the least
he's invasive the smallest right the
salary footprint yeah that's ever been
left on a house yes one yogurt moved a
couple pieces of furniture shoes shoes
off so according to the report the
homeowner noticed that vehicle titles
that he had spread out on the bed were
now put together inside a box underneath
the bed so this dude did clean dude he
was like there's paper's on this side
come on let's get your titles in order
to get all these like a real burglar
would find the the box where you keep
all your important documents and take
them out take them out yeah I better put
these back so someone doesn't find them
that's right so someone like he's being
arrested your stuff's under the bed I
cleaned it up I organized it by car if
I'm car making a year are you ready
for the sentence of this story that they
made it makes it a dumb people town
which so often is the case when it when
the perceived victim you start to
realize is a very active member of this
story I can't wait here it is the victim
told officer that his grandfather's
sword was now standing in the room's
corner and sheathed placed in the
bathroom
if you've got your grandfather's sword
which I don't even know
we're so far away from the last time
anyone needed a sword was your
grandfather a samurai nope nope nope
nope peaches probably Civil War
reenactor probably I mean did they use
swords in the real Civil War because if
if it does isn't that like the if the
homeowner is old like well I don't know
how old you have to be that's good we
will get to a delore yeah okay but he
could like my grandfather's sword don't
you think the cop a little bit was like
your sword you have a sword right right
yeah you can't just have a sword so the
owner is saying my sword which used to
be in the corner is now in the bathroom
no the sheath is in the bathroom the
sword is standing up in the corner Jay I
mean look sorry I feel like we're
solving an escape room the homeowner
told officers there was also ice cream
in the microwave that had been in the
freezer when he'd left his home look
sometimes it's 10 seconds by the way
it's not a bad idea again I do that with
butter is that weird you do seven
seconds with butter and it makes all the
difference in the world like in a dish
or the whole the deal I put your butter
from the thing in the microwave seven
seconds it spreads like it's great it
smells like butter
it's like no you don't it spreads like
margarine in the bedroom there was that
expression means something totally
different to you yes yes butter spreads
differently yes
it just hits it hits different Jay walks
around being like that was that was like
cutting through seven second butter yeah
that's that's like cutting through
microwave butter and J at a restaurant
excuse me
um was this in the microwave for
remember three seconds because it's
really hard to get through I'm not some
[__] clown in the bedroom there were
three hats and two shirts that did not
belong to the homeowner at the top of
the stairs lay a pair of unfamiliar
jeans unfamiliar jeans maybe my favorite
emo band
yeah
and I don't know enough about Taylor
Swift and I and I'll admit that to them
here on August if you told me on my
b-day if you told me that her new album
was called unfamiliar jeans oh yeah 100
belief to me unfamiliar jeans could be
like a an ancestry.com space
yes yep I mean for me it like three
shirts at the top of the yeah three
shirts that you don't recognize at the
top of the stairs these are the top of
the stairs that's a Jim Croce
I was gonna say that or a Third Eye
Blind song yeah for sure or Gordon
Lightfoot that one for two three sixes
at the top of the stairs the homeowner
also noted that Solomon was wearing his
shorts after officers arrived and he
came out of the house well he's not
gonna walk out so he wore the victim the
owner Donald Sutherlands
uh as the officers and the homeowner
completed the report the homeowner
noticed a blue push cart in the woods
behind his garage was not his the
inside's Like a Stranger Things episode
like all this stuff is happening it's a
riddle inside the cart were two
backpacks a jean jacket and other
personal belongings
within the backpacks and the jackets
officers found the following are we
taking the SAT yeah you're going to have
to repeat to me
this this is I'm getting nervous here's
what they found in the backpacks four
syringes probably not for great use of
sure two ID cards not belonging to
Solomon sure two debit cards one not
belonging to Solomon so one doesn't mean
that's mine one plastic bag containing a
white crystal powder substance this
sounds like this probably it sounds like
that scene from Trading Places yeah one
one bag this is a PCP Angel Dress you
know what this stuff does to kids this
is also unbelievable this is also what
Ben Affleck started out with to figure
out his identity in the movie yeah well
the white powder tested positive for
meth Believe It or Not officers arrested
Solomon without incident and transported
him to the Mahoney County Jail on the
charger burglary the homeowner told
officers that he had not locked his
doors prior to leaving the house okay
you gotta like I don't want a victim
blame but I don't either but who in this
day if you live in Death Valley yeah you
gotta lock your doors right the Lord
takes a cart he unlocks the door that's
right I'm gonna ask you guys this how
old is Alexander salom the guy who the
burglar yeah who the guy who just wanted
to be in the room where it happened he
wasn't the house when it happened the
house where it happened how old you want
to go first or you can go second or
third is it like Price is Right rules no
it's just closest to the places to the
pin we don't care yeah
um
50 50 15. that's great okay I like that
by the way that used to sound old now
that's younger than that uh you guys I
say this a lot I know where I'm
sidetracking We're Young you are not
your dad's 50. no you're you're not your
dad's 50 that's right we are not our
dads yeah every generation is not that
when you think about those true all
those guys
um I'm gonna say
67.
his name was I think he's 41. 41 yeah
okay
I mean I kind of want to know how old
the guys who he went whose grandfather's
story is sitting I want to know more
about a lot more two years alone with
his Grandpa's sword is this the new Odd
Couple yes two years along with this
grandfather that's a Jim Croce song Yes
Alexander Solomon will get out of here
two years of load with a grandfather so
it is I'm home again
30 years old wow I know I was right look
at him oh my God I like the look you
know shaved head beard you got it I
appreciate it yes she does he does look
a little like brother I took it yes I
got your jersey yes unfamiliar jeans top
of the stairs right you gotta go
upstairs I'll arrange a title it's also
like if you match like burglary styles
to Comedy Styles that's kind of is like
the Brodie Stevens style approach yes
all over
yeah
you probably walked it was like don't
liner G not good no gonna change it and
like Brody Stevens some people totally
get what he did in that shirt and also
people like I don't understand him and
Brody both fans of a good drum circle
that's right the straight up drugs oh
that's Story number one number one down
in the books when we come back we find
out stuff that how you can follow Dan
Mintz and what Yuri can see him on more
stuff and all that great stuff on the
end what we have going on the other side
of the break it's dumb people town with
our great guest Dan Mintz we'll be right
back
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we get into the stuff then how you can
follow and enjoy Dan Mintz let's just
tell you a little bit about what we have
going on and again we have we're kind of
backlogged so we're just we don't know
when this is dropping exactly okay we
should have a better idea of that stuff
by the way I don't know people listen
whenever they listen sure so someone
might be telling you what you missed out
on that's right so if this thing drops I
I have a feeling this will probably be
this is my favorite part if this thing
it doesn't matter whether it does or not
you tell me what you're doing Randy so
on uh on Monday July 24th Jay and I are
doing a stage show
I'm so excited I wrote an 80 a 90-page
script that we shaved down to 80 Pages
it's our stand up it's the story of us
getting switched when we were six weeks
old and we make the case for parenting
why people should choose to be parents
by spending an hour and a half telling
you how shitty it is to have kids it's a
weird Flex from the perspective of Two
Dads
we're not just two white guys we're the
same ones two one-man shows right yeah
so two men happening simultaneously so
it is we love this we're really proud of
it and I we sort of fashioned it in the
style of other people's stuff that we
really love Mike Birbiglia stuff Neil
Brennan stuff Alex edelman's got a great
show out there right now so we're
excited to put this up here in hopes of
maybe taking it off gentlemen Broadway
Broadway I'm so proud of him so anyway
that so we so we did that that's going
to be a dynasty typewriter two shows on
the 24th uh on uh August 1st we're doing
uh Target show at Largo which I you'd be
so hard to tag yourself because it's so
tight and so good but we'd love to have
you on because we were doing them at The
Comedy Store Dan did one that we did so
the target show just for you know and
we'll do another one in August as well
is our friends go on stage they do their
sets Jay and I are off to the side we're
writing tags and we come on stage
afterwards and Pitch you our tags
picturing like in between like you know
you do the whole set and then we come up
we're like and you love this you know
what's so great about it it's better for
the audience point of view it's great
because it's guaranteed laughs but also
from the comic point of view you cannot
have a bad set no because even if you're
set God forbid didn't really like go the
way you want it you're you're ending uh
the Brian Cox adaptation while I'm in
the end uh the ending is going to be you
to and them
guaranteed making laughs but when you
leave the stage you are going to be like
that was [__] that was great because
either I walked away with tags or
whatever so look at uh supersclass.com
all of our stuff there for that and Ann
Arbor we're an Ann Arbor in Ann Arbor in
uh in September September 8th and 9th
we'll find we'll tell you all about that
stuff is it nears Daniel where can
people see go to danielvankirk.com
things are getting locked in right now I
know that uh the 12th I will be doing a
show a monthly show that I do yeah the
12th of August in Houston and then maybe
a couple other dates around that and
then in September I'm at High Plains
Comedy Festival we get your passes right
now it's like the third or fourth
weekend in September I think it's like
21st 22nd 23rd and then
um in October I'm headlining a Comedy
Fest in Boston called yuck Fest and that
will be I think October 21st the big
news is that on 11 11 I will be taping
my special and album recording at the
Lincoln Lodge two shows that was my wish
yes on 11 11 I made that wish dude love
you for that so go and are you going to
stop at 11 11 and as an audience I'll
Make A Wish and meet back there a year
later you totally should I should you're
I will probably steal that I take it and
uh treat it like New Year's yeah and
then yeah yeah yeah that would be
hilarious if some comic did every show
The Late Show yeah they ran that long
like it was two years you should do that
for like it's almost midnight at that
moment you think everybody's Gonna Make
A Wish and you bring out like a bunch of
people from Bennigan's and they wish
happy birthday to one person if I could
pull it off if I could get to that Bert
level of shenanigans or just the staff
of Shenanigans so uh that's 11 11. it I
don't think tickets are on sale yet but
you should check whenever sell out go to
danielvankirk.com and I will be in Vegas
doing a week of shows at Brad Garrett's
Comedy Club to be announced soon as well
so a whole bunch of stuff even more
dates being added everything's at Daniel
Van Kirk damn it's where can people over
here they can obviously hear you on
Bob's Burgers
um yeah
um on Bob's Burgers side if this if you
wait long enough to drop this I can
promote my movie but do it do it right
do it past 10 one yet I'm just hoping
check that out look up if there is a
movie with me and then if there is go to
go see it TBD yeah uh stand up you're
around doing stand up here doing stand
up um I don't have a I'm not doing a ton
of stuff right now I have uh I wish I
remembered to look up when it is because
I forget exactly when but I I'm doing
like a festival and and also I don't
know if it's totally either totally
official or announced but I'm doing a
festival of all in Minneapolis also was
it the gray lakes or no what what sounds
we've done that we did that last year it
was amazing it's great and either and
it's time for beginning of October and
then it's October okay and then like
around that right around time uh at uh
Fort Collins oh yeah I love so we're
gonna do so many good things comedy for
it comedy four we're doing that in
October the first weekend
oh really that's right if you end up
with like an extra day
um we'll connect and uh follow me
there's uh Denver Comedy Underground is
also a great place to drop it I did a
couple shows there before I headlined
the growlics honestly Adam Kate and
Holland are those guys at those guys too
so if you don't understand you want to
do more is there a danmints.com that
people can check there's the damage.com
I don't have no what's on that at this
point of course
this is I I just have Instagram but uh
this is Dan Vince
um we should mentioned we're up on
threads all right oh yeah I guess yeah
we're up on threads
all right so
sent in by Jacob Benoit at Atmos fan
Atmos f-a-n like atmosphere but
atmosphere I'm a fan of the atmosphere
as well this is a major cautionary tale
this is what I my commentary on this I
love it to any young person and I'm
going to use this story to educate my
kids moving forward okay it's short but
it's crazy okay and I'm sure we'll have
a lot to say about it you have to just
be so careful what you do in general
what you say publicly on social media if
you're up on threads like us you know
especially if it has something to do
with your employment okay do not
understand don't make comments about
your employment the smallest thing can
get you in trouble in the biggest of
ways in this next story I'm guessing
like somebody who works at a Taco Bell
said like we have the worst food in the
world which they thought like who cares
about me and my social media and then
the headline is Taco Bell employee calls
out company for horrible and all of a
sudden you have way more relevance I
love that this is a great game right
because that's right what do you think
it is uh I think it's uh someone who
mentions that their boss is having an
affair with somebody else oh oh oh it
leaks that if it doesn't think anything
it doesn't think anyone's going to know
who these people are yeah they said
something like when your boss has sex
with your co-worker so you get stuck
with the extra worship you have to work
yeah you have to work on it yeah
do you have any thoughts as to what this
could be probably like Del Taco or
someone Delta okay
okay I do and I saw you thinking of that
so I'm gonna read the headline which
will dispel all of it woman loses NASA
internship after Twitter fight with a
member of space Council oh snap
that's completely Justified so it's a
whole new Star Wars yeah this is it
all right a woman's ex this is from wcmh
a woman's excitement over an internship
may have gotten the better of her you
dummy a woman identified only as Naomi H
which is my favorite Fountains of Wayne
song sure using a
product not Stacy H but there's a
definitely a something there's an Anna
ing who's a preparation
a woman identified only as Naomi H using
harsh language shared on Twitter that
NASA had accepted her for an internship
former NASA engineer yeah [__] I'm
going to space camp
in the right area
it's a former Nasser engineer and
October Sky author former Aunt NASA
engineer and October Sky author Homer
Hickam hold on really quick sorry about
October Skies the Jake chilling all
movie right that is yes and Vanilla Sky
is the Tom Cruise movie and Vanilla
Fudge is the character you played on
lips white lips
probably vanilla right yeah well if it
is white fudge well it is a white fudge
oh that is a thing so it is fun well
they're actually
they're white the white fudges like
white fudge like that's I don't know who
named the character Dan I'd have to come
up with your own flips white fudge fudge
cookie dude I wrote a script and John
keeps telling me to stop sending it
all right so former Nas engineer an
October Sky author Homer Hickam replied
uh to her tweet saying language that's
what they said wow okay that is some
condescending [__] that's some old guy
on a lawn so do you want to hear
language
correct I would write back correct yeah
you I did use it I feel like
she should not have this
what did she write you guys want to hear
what she wrote yes I want to know what
he said it's so innocuous it's so great
this is the exchange Naomi H his actual
tweet was everyone shut the [__] up I
got accepted for a NASA internship
that's not bad can I also say to she's
excited Mr October Skye not Mr October
yeah Homer Hickam yes
you want someone to be this this excited
and you want somebody to be spreading
this excitement about this type of work
and can I just say in a literal sense I
would love it if everyone shut the [__]
up right just sure
especially on Twitter especially on
Twitter right you could have just
stopped it up leave that yeah she was
excited shout it out I think this person
gets I think the person gets dinged if
it's a man or a woman because you just
don't you know what I mean like yeah
no matter what the gender I feel like it
feels a little bit more charged of like
an old white dude telling a young woman
it is but but yes he could have said
that to anybody I love that she came in
so hot I'm I'm so like you said I think
this shows I hope she comes back hot
like everyone was taught to me
the immense it presupposes that a lot of
people were talking [__] about her and
she needed to end it right there you're
not getting this internship what's your
rule even on Instagram do you respond to
comments uh I I'm very not good at
social media and I kind of had dragged
into having to do it yeah so I can
promote comedy shows but like I I should
respond I just respond less than I
should because I don't even respond to
good comments I just like I can't yeah
even when people do good comments he's
like everybody shut up a social media
like person told me because I was like I
don't want to wait in to come I very
rarely sometimes if I think what I'm
writing is so funny in response whether
they'll get it or not I'll respond but
they said uh just like them all
because even that says something to the
algorithm that like you are an
interactive account so then they promote
it negative so then they promote it to
you well that's a flex too that is such
a crazy because then they promote it to
more users because they want users to
get that endorphin they're like oh the
person I interacted with saw my thing
and so if I and sometimes I don't even
take the time but I will go through and
at least if I see the notification or in
real time
you really love interacting with people
and we do too I do to me I enjoy but it
lacks so much context on the internet
which is why so this woman by the way
didn't she said I got accepted for a
NASA internship all caps NASA Shin
hashtag NASA this is after shut the [__]
up yeah she didn't she everyone shut the
[__] up all caps I got a internet the
whole thing is I got the intern no I got
the internship at all caps NASA gotcha I
think how you spell that is correct on
the internet yeah right but I'm just
saying like no hashtag NASA no at Nasa
so no at home or oh so this guy almost
has a word alert yeah this [__]
no NASA
so right now I'm with the girl Naomi H
I'm like you're gonna have a hard time
getting me off for her right right oh
really come on I'm gonna get you off I'm
Gonna Get You
can shoot him up for a right no hey
don't clip that I'm gonna get you offer
right now well that response got an even
crazy response from Naomi age back to
Homer Hickam who said no they replied
suck my dick and balls I'm working
if I don't care if we do it for
ourselves that should be a t-shirt suck
my dick and balls I'm working for NASA
she needs to start making that oh my God
I'd buy that shirt one small step for
man [__]
I think it's as comedians I think it's
funny
yes I agree it does give it a little
more but anybody who wrote back to this
dude he writes language thinking I've
said it all and she's and she was like
no I'll say it all so his response back
there is amazing too this is all he said
replied and I'm on the National Space
Council that oversees NASA that's it so
that so now you're just sweating all the
color rushes wet down the back have you
ever flopped sweat on stage and like had
that moment so she's having this moment
she's flop sweating because you can't
delete it it's in the middle of a bit
that an audience which takes me a little
bit off for her
she didn't look at who wrote that you
got it when you go back at someone and
again you're kind of like in the grand
scheme of things as I still love her
response sure but I don't think she
would have made it had she knew she was
talking to a angry old dude so again
again who could decide this is all of
argument about her enthusiasm and what I
would say to Homer Hickam is this person
is so excited about it you don't want to
Temporary do it the wrong way but at the
same time you're right if she'd look she
probably wouldn't have done it is one of
is one of more than well yeah how do you
know I mean I feel if it were if it were
me it's like the the opportunity like
knowing for sure you lose your ownership
like not none of those interns are going
to be astronauts like right this is like
so funny to to tweet that back I agree
the comedy does almost supersize I would
have I feel like she should have fully
knowing who it was so do you want her to
have known it was that would be that oh
I know
having just listened to the dead eyes
podcast which I love have you heard that
whole podcast yeah uh most of it yeah
right yeah I love it unbelievable to me
this is like her dead eyes moment like
she stepped deep into this thing she I
hope she gets fired because then she may
turn this into something beautiful right
it's the best story of like learning
from a machine and on her next job
interview be like I got embroiled in a
Twitter thing that I will never do again
I learned do you want to be the person
who goes so what happened with that we
fired her we fired someone who made a
maybe a mistake that was very funny and
really really really wanted to work here
so I think it's oh good yeah but I think
like NASA's like look we are a very this
buttoned up outfit exactly we can't
allow people to like go this isn't
SpaceX yeah and wherever it's like
banging each other in their cubicles
exactly allegedly
so here comes one of more than two dozen
people named to the newly created
National Space Council users Advisory
Group newly created so maybe she didn't
know okay language indeed word word
eventually came out uh that Naomi had
lost her internship the response from
Twitter users was mixed
and I'll give you some of the responses
okay this is a normal practice I don't
feel bad for someone who told their boss
publicly that she'd be uh she should be
more careful bosses not her boss not her
boss not her boss and unknowing misnomer
welcome to the internet where your life
is uh is public and recorded and you
have no personal life if you want a
professional job you act professionally
and that's at vorkitec Jacob later wrote
about the incident on his blog saying he
had nothing to do with her getting fired
I don't know about that he said I'm a
Vietnam vet and I'm not at all offended
by the f word however when I saw NASA
and the word used together it occurred
to me that this young person might get
in trouble if NASA the side so I tweeted
in her one word language which didn't
provide any of the context that you just
said you just so here's how I would have
handled it if I were like he could have
written by like him congrats just so you
know careful they get weird about that
follow her
see if she'll follow you back in a
direct message say hey I just want you
to know that I the white shirts I've
done some work at Nasa just that for
your own thing I want to make sure you
don't get in trouble because it's a
great opportunity like that's what I
mean that's what he's claimed you know
why because he doesn't want to I wrote
One condescending term hoping that that
would come across two people at Nasa and
said fire the [__] am I a bad person I
didn't specifically do the [__] I said
you guys do what you want you should
fire up you guys do what you want fire
her whatever you if I show up and I see
her in these Halls I'm gonna light the
place on fire
I'm just a hidden figure that's right
damn very good soon her friends took
Umbridge and said a lot of unkind things
but long after I was gone as I
immediately deleted my comments and
blocked all concerns so her friends
started coming for homerican which
doesn't help no you're like I don't guys
please don't you're making your third
friend of yours who's drunker than
everybody else at the bar now wants to
get in a fight with someone's girlfriend
you're like stop stop it's also a rule I
tend to say there's there's no mean
thing you're gonna say that's gonna make
them rehire me so now Homer Hickam later
I learned she had lost her offer for an
internship with NASA this had nothing to
do with nor could I since I do not hire
and fire the agency or at the agency or
have any say unemployment there's also
every Mafia boss's defense right right
yeah I didn't I didn't I'm not I didn't
shoot anything I'm not telling anybody
to do anything I had nothing to do I
made one eye movement that was it I
looked up I looked up at the light for
two seconds am I a bad person right as
it turned out it was due to the NASA
hashtag her friends used
that called the agency's attention to a
lot so like had her friends not come in
there and hashtag math story so Naomi's
friends got her in trouble they started
hashtagging now you just don't do that
hashtag NASA Naomi eventually reached
out to Homer Hickam and apologized take
him after the conversation Hickam had
kind words to say about Naomi he also
said he would help her find a better
position so see this is coming right she
reached out to me with an unnecessary
apology which I heartily accepted and
returned with my own after talking to
her I'm certain she deserves a position
in the Aerospace industry and I'm doing
all that I can to secure her one that
will be better than the one she lost
it's also intense this is cool she did
not write those tweets no two
that was very jokey she was she wasn't
writing her first thing to offend
anybody right she was writing her thing
to exclaim how excited she was let's
look at it she wasn't like let's see
what the stuff shirts down at nasty
she's not running the [__] like
bearings give her the lead no one's
gonna be like hey let's see what the
intern thinks about this next uh shuttle
line right this isn't Blackberry
I kind of feel like if it's it if you're
gonna say that like she it's it's her
fault for just not that she should have
known the consequences yeah like it's
his fault he should have known the
consequence that he might get her fired
even if he works
seasoned further down the line person
you could easily follow her if you
really care if this thing is like he
should have followed her so I said you
should have followed him no Dan's so
right if he's really concerned right or
like [__] I didn't mean for that to
happen he should said hey guys you
cannot fire her now right so because so
listen it's on me I have also talked to
the folks that had to do with her
internship and made absolutely certain
there will be no black mark on a record
so he's trying I mean that's a little
after the fact but he is he did reach
out to them
listening or the three of you ever see a
follow-up to what happens with her and
her career path I'm invested in again
but this is a wonderful cautionary tale
that didn't happen to my kids and if my
kids ever get something that is good
don't
tweet out shut the [__] up I got a job
yeah that's for Threads right that's for
Threads and we're up on threads all
right that is uh that I'm gonna I love
that little story that second story I'm
gonna pass this to Jay Jay can you give
us a little teaser a little taste is Jay
of of what we could be seeing Crossing
camera frame Jay's gonna sit down he's
gonna give us a little taste of what
we're going to see this is in the rough
and uh Story number three in a rough and
tumble world of fast food
um not everyone's cut out for it there
you go all right well uh mints is our
guest I'm so excited it's dumb people
down One More Story Jay's gonna bring us
home we'll be right back
[Music]
hey we want to thank our sponsor bird
dog they are amazing shorts that
actually fit because the material
stretches around you you feel good they
look like nice khaki shorts but then
they function like your best pair of
gyms with that Mobility I love it
there's a Slimmer fit through the thigh
I don't even tell you say goodbye to all
your other shorts this will
revolutionize your short drawer yes it
works as it were you don't want to
restrict your movement and they fixed
that issue by inventing Cloud knit
fabric that looks just like khaki they
use an anti-stink sweat wicking fabric
that keeps you cool and dry so I put
these on first of all you can get them
like a little longer if you like a nine
they're a nine inch seam yep I go with
the six inch one I got the legs to back
it up damn straight Daniel and sometimes
when shorts are a little high they kind
of restrict your movement even more
right you know if there's that weird
place between too long and I'm wearing
like these are stretches I'm a 2002 NBA
player and then you're in a Sublime
cover man and but if you get too high
you can go the other way bird dogs are
perfect man I get that six inch seam yep
and you know what I like the colors yes
they did like uh this one I have is like
a I almost said metal that it makes it
weirder but it's like a bluish yeah a
bluish here I'm gonna make up a color
it's bluish dope Periwinkle no
Periwinkles not made up I don't know but
so I wore on playing golf look Global
warming's here to stay uh it's only
getting hotter I wore them playing golf
and I normally sweat a lot when I go I I
did not sweat as much and I'm gonna say
this little nestled when you put on I
played better at golf now I don't know
if I can attribute that to them I was
down to three putts three fives so the
bird dog look they're amazing I love it
they don't stand by that golf claim but
we do I'm going to okay so go to
birddogs.com DPT and enter promo code
DPT for a free Yeti style tumbler with
your order it's very good fits it's
large and fits perfect in my cup holder
yep which sometimes you get one or the
other large doesn't feel big right small
I'm like Goldilocks but I'm right in the
perfect you got the right Tumblr it's
like the shorts go to birddogs.com
that's birddogs.com d p t and promo code
DPT for a free Yeti style tumbler and
some great shorts that you can buy do it
let's get
sticker hey guys welcome back to the
show Dan Daniel Jay take us home okay
here's the headline okay woman quits
office job to work at McDonald's
maybe that's its own story breaks down
in tears after one shift I believe it
you think it's easy you think that I
mean you understand how he not how easy
but how cushion I went to the McDonald's
with my nephews the McDonald's okay well
it's Rochelle so it's the McDonald's but
I love that you said I went to the
McDonald's like there was only one no
it's the one in Rochelle yeah right
there is technically two but one's off
by the interstate I think that's not
ours right we don't claim that the
McDonald's next to Country School which
I'm more of a fan I know the McDonald's
we go to McDonald's on the 4th of July
at 11 o'clock at night with my nephews
you already know if you have kids I am
not telling their parents that I'm doing
this also I'm gonna assume the place is
packed you are 100 I'm loaded because we
drove by an in and out my son wanted a
burger after we saw fireworks and we're
driving because everybody goes there
everyone goes they've like either like
been drinking or they picked you know
steak to their claim at [__] 2 p.m
and they're like we need food for hours
yeah yeah yes and I we went because uh
my nephews talked me into uh watching
the Super Mario movie with them and with
the promise of late night McDonald's
you're giving your nephews I mean when
we were kids that was like the greatest
thing ever was like a movie and movie
McDonald's my aunt and uncle who's their
grandparents we're like uh you better
call their mom and tell them that you're
doing this you better do it and I go
what
and they're like I'm just saying and I
go guys first of all part of the fun of
this is Mom doesn't know right but I
said fine right so I step out so that
they don't know they still think we're
doing like Renegade fun and I call and
uh I'm talking to her and I go hey so
here's the deal
I'm taking your kids to go watch this
movie at my mom's place we're gonna stay
up late we're starting it late and I may
sneakily get them late night McDonald's
and tour credit she goes it's summer and
it's right it's exactly right I go she's
like what I don't care are you more
relaxed in summertime with your kids uh
I I don't even know think about what
season it is
La it's kind of always feels like summer
yeah there's no school the no schoolness
of it all I mean I'm pretty relaxed
about like McDonald's because I I feel
like it's all
um I mean obviously there's healthier
food but yes there's lots of food you
give them that is just as bad that you
don't think about because it's from a
local true whatever and it doesn't have
the cultural that's Whole Foods makes
chicken nuggets too I'm just saying it's
all we're saying anyway we went they
wanted the Grimace meal and all that
whole shebang yeah and uh and the
Nuggets by the way you guys came up
because my nephews each got like a six
piece or whatever you know I have
friends who could each eat 50 of those
oh God yeah and they were like I bet I
could too and I'm like you cannot you
can absolutely 50 pieces especially
I can I could eat 220 pieces today not
and right now and not even bat an eye
yeah what's your number on nuggets I I
don't have a number
and I'm good I'm like okay not one of my
numbers
now if we're talking what's your number
one nuggets 9-1-1 right so anyway yeah
I'm sorry to do this big deal it was
slammed and the people working there
were like over the edge like the scene
where like the sub the submarine
realizes that the German sub is close
and everything goes into full and you're
doing nine things at once that's what
was happening so you tell me this woman
broke down I [__] well believe it I
believe it okay so it's not very often
that corporate workers just oh this by
the way was sent in by Matthew Freeman
and not your average Matt
um it's not very often the corporate
workers decide to switch up their
careers by moving in the fast food
industry but that's what tick tocker I
already uh lazy Mariah so now I feel
like she broke down be like for the for
the tick tocker put out the video or the
about what she got fed up with working
from home oh she's the person okay yes
so in a viral video the former office
employee showed herself getting dressed
in her McDonald's attire for the first
time great while going over all the
reasons for her sudden career change yes
all right while the woman was definitely
loving it at first how much do you hate
this I hate it I hate it things quickly
turned South what's that you put that in
no no now you're trying to no I'm not
blame it on
Jay's angling for that McDonald's
sponsorship 50 nuggets and he's loving
it dude I mean seriously that's Brian
Cox I know he's made succession bump
whatever
um things quickly turned South when she
realized just how stressful working at
McDonald's actually was causing her to
break down and start crying you think
the crying was real no I don't know man
if they were slammed and somebody said I
want fries with no salt which then they
have to like redo a whole bin of them
it's like cleaning I pass over it's like
I've been in bars bartending back in the
day when we were so slammed and someone
broke glass on near the ice well oh my
God so you burn it and you don't have a
choice you have to worse kill all that
ice everything and then you have to
clean the whole thing out and it doesn't
matter how many people are waiting for
drinks
I mean one time I ate broken glass by
accident on purpose because I didn't
realize there were yes it's fine nothing
happened I think you got it down I do I
didn't know how big were the pieces I
noticed they're pretty tiny shards it
was like when were you in prison
I bought it too I think a glass broke
and the dishwasher and got on yeah yeah
and you didn't have any Cuts I mean I
guess I felt mentally upset about it but
sure he was emotionally cool yeah coming
up according to lasia working from home
was making her lazy uh lazy that's not
in there
I did that one all right things got me
dialed in on it
I want to hear the other ten that got
that you cut I know
he's like he's like no no I didn't cut
anything yeah they're all in there I
need to be out of the house to be
motivated so I got a job out of the
house just to get me out
this is her quote I need to be out of
the house so I got a job out of the
house just to get me out
I'd be like so you want to work from
home she said I and she explained I find
I get more done when I have things to do
shut up shut up stop I'm so sick of you
I'm gonna cry these are the people at
like first day at Camp who go ah I like
to have a good time or people no [__] I
like to laugh people who like to be
constantly this is like a woman who
constantly uses the phrase you do you I
hate you do you I am what I am you do
you hey you do you yeah if you are what
you are then you do you can I ask you a
question nobody has to be on the spot
you don't have to answer it I'm only I'm
positing it because I obviously have one
is there a profession not in this that
you ever daydream about having that is
so different from what we do like I have
had Daydreams about running and owning a
landscaping business
where I just show up to a lawn I think
because I used to work on farms you know
and we would get there and the field
would be full and at the end of the day
it would be empty and then the next day
we'd take all that stuff to an empty
barn and at the end of the day the barn
would be full it felt so gratifying and
I watched tick tocks of people like
cleaning a sidewalk and like trimming a
yard and bushes and satisfying I know
and I look at people's stuff and I'm
like if I had the tool I would just go
to this apartment complex just fix these
clean it up Landscaping I think is a get
outside of my house get outside of
Comedy there's a baby getting in a
middle and an end to it it just feels so
gratifying but I just don't I think
anything anything that is fun to do on
your own becomes terrible when it's a
job yeah like I just like if you're like
editing your own videos it's like this
is really cool like but like then then
if you ever see like an at like a
professional editor like working on
deadlines and having a like 12 people
give them different notes
yeah they're doing it yeah because your
Daydream is always the best case
scenario
it wasn't a day you didn't want to do it
when you picture yourself yeah like also
like you don't have the owner of the
apartment complex being like why'd you
cut the shrubs like that you're right
that's way too short way too short now
you can see too much of the side of the
building now why I have to wait three
weeks I'm not paying you so she wants to
get out so she got out and she got out
uh so far she hasn't revealed whether or
not she's actually decided to go back to
work at the golden arches but it just
goes to show that working in the fast
food industry can be very daunting no
that's the end of the article that's it
that's it that's all very daunting you
talk to Taco Bell employees after
midnight dude when we came in high
school we used to come in high school we
we would eat tacos see these two ten
times we have an eating problem
solution that's what I'm discovering
yeah that's what we've revealed today
yes that we have a problem so uh the
moral of this story is don't do
something for the sake of tick tock it
might be great that's it it literally
might break you think about what you're
doing for the sake also I would argue in
the opposite direction it's good to cry
every once in a while agree it's good to
have I said that to my daughter my
daughter was crying about like I hurt my
shoulder in a basketball game and I came
home and I and I was like I think my
shoulders messed up for life of course
I'd take the most life though and I
literally I'm like it might be separated
my and my daughter started crying on my
behalf and my wife was like wait you
didn't cry this much when I told you I
had breast cancer and I was like yes she
didn't understand that like it makes
sense and I'm like wait a second this
I'm like Let Her Cry it feels so good it
feels good have you cried ever like I've
cried recently watching something some
movie or a bear I cry every episode I
cried watching something and I was like
this feels so [__] good and I've
cried for other reasons so maybe this
felt great for her if it's real if sure
so it's tick tock so I don't think it's
I doubt it's real fake tears I just feel
bad for like the supervisor and the
other employees that are now like
dealing with a crying person well also
just like we have to wait and find out
if someone's coming in tomorrow yeah
they're reading like oh she's getting a
lot of comments saying go back guys so
she might be here she might be here
right on her being here and then we have
to deal with her crying while we're
trying to deal with the rush with all
these people coming in for the grandma
all right that's a great little that's a
show Dan Mintz you were fantastic I
loved him listen to him Daniel and Dan
on uh on Bob's Burgers and then look out
for that Festival that he's at and the
movie and the eventual movie and the
movie that's coming out it's going to be
in the Marvel Universe the end and I
might be when I directed or wrote I
don't have any ideas I mean it could be
all three yeah and you heard about it
here first it's gonna be it's gonna be
the new Iron Man all right so uh that is
a show we love you guys and oh [__] we
gotta get back to work
[Music]